non è come sembra
come stai ciao allora no non dare fuoco
a dare fuoco un testimone è sparito il
nostro cavallo in qualche modo lui ne sa
qualcosa hai rubato il cavallo brutto
deficiente cose da dire todisco e pa
parla è un alibi interessante base di
ragazzi voglio che sono video sono fuori
già oggi siamo davanti su minecraft
perché sono freghi perché dovrebbe
mancare soltanto un dungeon ovvero il
danno è una festa all'entrata del
portale del never davvero mai pietra
nella canzone sei un attimo che sto
mangiava dalla fa mi tuffai e bocelli
perché occhi di york va bene facciamo un
po beni che mio contrario 2 cammino tipo
avrebbe voluto dai praticamente a ecco
cosa c'è una via e un villaggio credo
che una roba sopra la montagna di pietro
c'è un villaggio in back ne so c'è una
mucca qua io l'havana bach e male la
vacca che mi sono cagato plesso mezzo
jump square
ecco questo qua sembra più un dito medio
te lo dedico è un albero grazie prego
cosa sto vedendo nella vita a visita non
è un è un dungeon di studiare rende
l'accesso a rendere questa roba da
creativo che sono forte in un po i sogni
in ferro non posso che il mio secondo
rio che come sono scusa ma tu sei con
tendiamo a non me lo ricordavo così
entriamo ma una madame un secondo un
sembrando stanza vice niente lui davanti
a fido tanto il mice chiave la sono
praticamente
la germania gli scotti o fly cosa vedo
questa roba alimentare dobbiamo minare
così luciano son o pur andando subito
non so cosa sia sentono rumori
stranissimi spacca tutti risponde ai a
perth dove sono
no non ci sono distinzioni spacca tutto
ok loro c'è una roba quale di spaccare
con l'ossidiana di spaccare tu non so
dove stiamo andando e stato spiegato in
attimo cosa dovrebbe essere questa roba
è il portale per le cieli dungeon per il
portale del land teoricamente con
dungeon prima del portale del land è
praticamente siro ma basterebbe qualche
ma non è che ogni sala ci sono nemici
più difficili mi sa di sì vai
spaccatutto rompe tutto quanto non vi
risponderà rompi rompi romeo capitola
che posso fare tutto io ne rompe ma non
possiamo scavare andare di sotto non
c'era bello bravo e non mi ricordavo vai
vai se mi fanno male però mai
particolarmente tra chiuditi richeri
critici come il cosi non ce li ho dietro
sapeva yemen ai è questa qua ci sono c'è
gente si sente mena a vela spa one two e
distrugge con di stucco me disturbo io
non sono gli spot dei beni aia scusa non
volevo spaccare gli cosi spacca li
uccide e distrugge cosi fa qualcosa sono
un casino primo colore molto prematuro
agli non è vero non sei stato tu ma da
cosa
guardali così veloce cavaliere nero mia
storia mi ha fatto malissimo spacca i
vari stragi e cose che parlo vince è la
luce molto ma non da chi male lo re e la
donna che male cross per te sto morendo
per un secondo me the torch e torce per
terre le torce no
come so niente l'aumento o metto le
docce o spacco e cosi vai vai in cucina
sì c'è il portale cioè portare vai entra
ci siamo siamo arrivati all and now mi
spendo no
pietro non ho archi non ho niente di
meno non mi vedono
non ho guardati da mirato a caso aveva
attaccato meno sporca nuovo scivolo ora
sono morte soprattutto minuti sul
morbido sono caduto e bene ho perso
tutto quanto perso ho capito e jordi
gesù in terra non è vero sto prendo io
dopo la gara non è vero nella vita
while the fuck hai visto che c'era poi
dopo li ho visto sì c'era un casino
cigan castello enorme e adesso dove
dobbiamo farlo fuori senza la god this
world e senza le armature godley perché
lo perse cadendo non abbiamo più niente
pietro si affacciava vince a metà forse
la casa ti ricordo prima cosa che le
navi messa visto delle robe dentro il
nuovo peso due stati di diamanti e kone
ancora veloci andiamo li mandiamo a gesù
l'ho visto a sprintare più neanche ok
perfetto per pato
no non c'è un asse che come no e ancora
a ok quasi le scuse ora nell'altro è
bene ma possiamo rifarci tutto in
diamante anche voci sul suo conto frecce
di la cina 53 e bepi viviamo non può le
cose con calma
va bene dove non solo niente lancio e
uova al drago lasciamole le robe lascia
una cesta fuori poi con degli amanti che
se dobbiamo se dovessimo morire di nuovo
cava ca o due uova le uova come faccio
le vuole
il papa infatti sa niente delle uova
grazie a dio che abbiamo lasciato quel
diamante armeno andremo senza niente ma
veramente non c'è modo per settare lo
spawn liti potermi re dovremmo dormire
ai diretti come questo elettrica e
stupende la lana ce l'hai
ma non ce l'ho l'ora sono morto secondo
faccia tumefatta risponde stizzito bagno
cioè buio vai vai vai sei pronto allora
pronto si va c 6 3 2 1 dai ok ora non
guardare subito non guarda lì non
guardate guardate no core di subito
presso fortezza bye bye bye
ok ok più che potrebbe esserci qualcuno
dentro non so e immagino sia un piacere
provato o chiamare che male c'è ma scusi
l'arco ho bisogno come il pane
però se uno pensa come prima secondo qui
chiudiamo ma non chiudiamo 1 scherzando
ok non abbiamo ancora dei dolori
precedono la mia martini a spacca che
uccide ucciso di male madhya pradesh e
sta gente uno solo scusa dai che lo so e
lo sto grando io ok ok io salgo su
intanto la witt chi ha tempo per morire
no non sto chiedendo una radio picchio
linea valeva niente va bene nuova tv
anche una funzione particolare si
conosceva bene a posizione particolare
da qua comunque se spacchiamo centofiori
sopra
chi è che ha picchiato un drago ruby
nuova beh stiamo scherzando non piccoli
cristalli intanto ore
poi di quel carico ora è quanto risponde
nessuno quindi sono però vi di un caffè
ne sono andati infatti giusta di tutti i
giochi che rendermi indietro e manda non
mi beccano colpisce colpisce colpisce
uffici ma egli sa chi è male forte
poteri dirmi ad aggiustare anni fa rose
mentre stavano infatti della dadt non
ascolti il talent raccolto 80 vita
finora è visto quanto inoltre vita ma è
impossibile se al timone o vita sta
arrivando colpito però ok però è una
cosa positiva al te senti e noi si
genera forti o generali h mentre in
corner l'attacco che però mi ha dato che
presa vado che cerchino essi dobbiamo
miglior mi ha messo rimasti pro 50 frecc
non è anche meno 39 formalmente
annunciato da preso preso con calma e
con calma pala colpo sicuro e spara
spara anche un pò sicuro
bravissimo grazie grazie madonna
colpo sicuro pettino deficiente eccolo
vai no no no ho capito tante volte ho
chiari primo chiuso forze libiche si
sono fatte di pisa vedo che è successo
non capisco non capisco niente
la ragazza l'aveva per cosa vedo lì
occhio e sali salita lo devo occupato da
tempo occupato sali per non cadere
nessun motore è poi sotto su un tipo 52
scritti di suo interesse anche come sia
possibile ma come vogliono spoiler ed un
accumulo di quadri stava stuprando tel
mi fa piacere ma data che casino sento
mai fatta cadere la prima arriva arriva
bagnati
non so come le altre ma dov è perfetto
perfetto è stato questa è stata molto
buona ma dona sentire pure se solo
riuscissimo a prendere le frecce che
hanno sì scheletri salverà body ma dopo
anche la torre vicine brani scheletri
madonna quanti iscritti
ora mi spieghi le mancate come
immanicato come con tutte le mancate e
non riuscivo arrivare a riva piano che
mi colpisce come quando devo fare io
l'ultimo no perché 10 frecce occhi
arriveremo
dai si sente frecce non finire ancora
che vai o no
ancora cinque frecce cia dovevo fare una
volta buona questo loro questa volta
buona mai perfetto se risulti dimmi
dimmi se voglio vedere dove troppa
l'uomo l'aveva trovato va bene senti tu
no da te io andrò ariston
se vuoi sì però e dovremo camminare nel
vuoto mentre ci sono degli scheletri che
ci stanno mirando in faccia non è
proprio marco vai vai se tattica una
bellissima e lo so che il purissima five
anci ma ce l'ho fatta
pensaci t'ammazzano giuro che avrei
buttato giù di brutto ragazzi guardate
mi voglio parlare gli under man city
incazzati che peccato
senior iii e anche quest'isola è stata
completata ci abbiamo messo un sacco è
stato molto difficile da usare le ultime
frecce che avevamo disponibili ma siamo
riusciti
quindi ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto
cosa momento mi piace anche tiziano
vestiti iscrivetevi e non ci vediamo da
un posto non ridere cosa di fatto quando
rivedrà il video non devi vivere
devi ridere con telecomando nell'occhio
fa malissimo da ragazzi
[Musica]